nuevo bloque y último de economía el día
en directo américa de france en ti 4 ya
está lista en el estudio conmigo jorge
hurtado jorge iniciamos en brasil donde
el banco central de ese país busca
frenar la inflación así es bueno el
banco central brasileño elevó la tasa
básica de intereses en 15 puntos
porcentuales hasta el 10,75 anual la
decisión raúl se da pese a que el
aumento de los precios puede afectar la
economía brasileña que se encuentra en
recesión técnica esta sería la octava
alza seguida de los tipos una decisión
unánime del comité de política económica
del banco central el aumento de los
tipos de interés se traduce en menos
créditos disponibles algo que puede
ralentizar la economía y elevar los
gastos de la deuda pública brasil
termina 2021 con la inflación del 10 6%
el doble del techo de meta del banco
central según las últimas previsiones
del boletín focus del banco central la
inflación se desacelerará en 2022 y se
ubicará en 5,38 por ciento este año
aunque el banco central estima que los
tipos se elevarán hasta el 12% en el
primer semestre de este año cerrará en
2022 en 11 75 y se van a reducir a ocho
por ciento el próximo 2023 hoy y también
el banco de inglaterra subió los tipos
de interés por segunda vez está en tres
meses así es y bueno lo hizo
principalmente presionado por frenar la
inflación el comité de política
monetaria del banco de lobos un tipo de
interés básico del 0.25 por ciento al 0
5 por ciento asimismo anunció una
reducción de estímulo que incluyen una
inversión gran una reversión gradual de
su enorme plan de compra de bonos según
bloomberg los economistas también
esperan un anuncio del ministro de
financia para contener el aumento del 50
por ciento en las facturas de energía de
los hogares actualmente la inflación se
ubica en 5,4 por ciento y es un máximo
en casi 30 años el banco espera que la
inflación llegue al 7 por ciento esta
primavera boreal nos quedamos en europa
jorge pero con los precios de la
gasolina esto en españa el precio de la
gasolina subió por quinta semana
consecutiva hasta marcar un nuevo récord
este sería el precio más caro para los
españoles desde el máximo histórico
registrado en septiembre del 2012
de 9 años así lo confirmó el boletín
petrolero de la unión europea la
gasolina se vende a 153 euros en litro
mientras el diésel o el gasóleo como le
dicen por allá se vende por 142 euros
actualmente en españa un litro de
gasolina cuesta lo mismo que dos litros
de leche o que tres barras de pan el
aumento del precio de la gasolina ha
sido del 24% en los últimos 12 meses la
tasa de inflación anual de españa se
redujo al 6% en enero desde un máximo de
casi 30 años del 6,7 por ciento que
registró en diciembre pasado y repasamos
los principales resultados
empresariales en la bolsa a jorge raúl
arrancamos con tu playlist favorito
sport ifai y las acciones cayeron
después de que la empresa informara de
una pérdida trimestral la compañía
perdió 444 millones de dólares y
proyectos que su margen de beneficios
del primer trimestre de 2022 caería el
25 por ciento desde el 26 5% la empresa
no mencionó la polémica por el podcast
de joe rogan cuyas declaraciones sobre
las vacunas contra el cómic 19
buscaron la salida de varios músicos de
la plataforma vamos con meta las
acciones de la empresa matriz de
facebook cayeron un 20 por ciento en la
sesión previa luego de que anunciara que
el crecimiento de usuarios apenas fue
del 8 por ciento en un año para todos
sus productos tictoc le ganó terreno con
los usuarios y la empresa admite que no
ha sido fácil monetizar los riles las
historias con vídeos que lanzó para
competir con la aplicación china child
aumentó su dividendo y la recompra de
acciones después de que los beneficios
del cuarto trimestre alcanzaron su nivel
más alto en mucho años esto gracias a
que los precios del petróleo se
dispararon por la preocupación de la
demanda y la reapertura de varias
economías él dijo que esperaba aumentar
su dividendo en un 4 por ciento en el
primer trimestre de 2022 hasta el 0.25
dólares por cada acción de indicadores
empezamos con asia las acciones
asiáticas cayeron por los malos
resultados de las tecnológicas en wall
street mientras en europa las acciones
cayeron por la preocupación de nuevos
aumentos de los tipos de interés y el
endurecimiento de la pola monetaria que
se hicieron realidad con la subida de
los tipos de interés el banco central de
inglaterra para finalizar ya que nos
trae como cifra el día la inflación
anual de turquía se disparó en enero a
su nivel más alto en 20 años el
48,69 por ciento ahí el presidente
tayyip erdogán promueve recortes a los
tipos de interés que han provocado la
caída de la moneda local por desgracias
entonces por toda la información
económica por el día de hoy nos vemos
mañana con más ahora pasamos directo a
parís ya está lista a natalia
[Música]